quoi de neuf Docteur 18 de la vieux prof
de tennis qui me disait ça quoi vous
l'avez l'économiste ou pas
[Musique]
bonsoir si je vous dis au secours au ici
debout dans le lit de cette rivière à
sec vous vous sentez peut-être concerné
parce que dans certaines régions de
l'eau bah il y en a plus
s'approvisionner en eau et devenue un
combat quotidien pour randine qui part
de nouveau remplir ces dizaines de
bouteilles chez sa cousine qui elle a
encore de l'eau qui coule dans ses
robinets confronté à sa plus grande
sèche reste depuis 26 ans Mayotte qui
dépend des eaux pluviales pour ses
besoins et presque à sec un strict
rationnement a été mis en place par les
autorités locales avec un accès à l'eau
potable un jour sur trois seulement
sur
des clés à l'autorisation de prélever
plus de 3 millions de mètres de haut par
an dans les par
à cela s'ajoutent les deux tours de
mètres cubes de consommer chaque année
par les habitants les agriculteurs et
les entreprises du canton le vocal Artis
sur une situation on perçoit que la
majoration des cartes
sé